what is John like as a director or more
importantly what was he like directing
this film John fun as a director because
he's having such a good time I mean you
know there's there's something about
he's his vision it's coming to life this
is something that he's thought about
he's dreamed up he's written it down in
in longhand and there it is
no ad-libbing no oh god no I'm in the
writers guild if you want to write join
the writers guild you can reading oh
yeah if you didn't like it how you said
you say no say it like this I know I
don't do that anymore but I know that's
what all actors hate and I gave so many
line readings people said we're not your
puppets yes you were oh no we were early
on we were definitely puppets he read
all of our lines exactly the same in our
rehearsal were you a puppeteer I never
met a director who didn't have puppets a
little bit a little bit but I think when
I watched this film you know again you
know as your daughter a mulatto
you know I know it's written but I but I
thought maybe just maybe you know there
was something spun in it so you know the
energy in the film reflects the energy
of you as a person which is very open
and free so I wouldn't assume you were a
puppet and you were drivel I don't mean
it that way I meant like but most
directors always played with puppets you
always read about them when they were
young so to me I just said the David
Locker is the one that always used to
say that we're not your puppets and say
yes you are but uh and today I'm a
little loser sort of but I still like a
dialogue I liked it you know because I
don't have time on the set you know I
got to get the shots I got it you know
if we're gonna work something out we'd
do that at rehearsal I always have a lot
of rehearsal that's what I was going to
say we did relatively few takes of
everything that's something that really
you know because I was really young when
I did it and then that was my first
feature as well and then subsequently I
realized that it wasn't like that in
other sometimes you did it like 36 times
and you were like ah but with John he
was really concise and really direct and
had great direction and a real point of
view and then you would do it three
times a safety move on so when this
piece came to you had you heard of John
Ward you seen his
work yes yeah I saw in college went to
Temple University I was actually a math
major and and the Student Activity
Center there was they showed three films
and there was an x-rated film called
pink flamingos I was like yo college is
cool they shall pour this is great
and so I wait you had to see this this
what I thought was gonna be an x-rated
film before and it was not I have sex
and pink flamingos I thought it was very
hot so yeah that was that was my first
introduction to John's work and for
those of you who have not seen Bigfoot I
guess everybody here eyes that last
scene just ate my head dolls are like oh
my god and then I remember a fight and
say hey you know Jon Huertas wants to
meet you for his film and I was like I'm
not eating dog doesn't want with me
because I gotta say when I met John I
don't know if you remember this but it
was a if I don't call back it was John
and Pat Petch it'll be up here tube yeah
Pat Moran's here who really asked them
that work with me at all you wouldn't be
here it wasn't for John and Pat but so
was the two of them and I walked in the
room and I don't know what to expect
that you know I'm still thinking you
know there's gonna be dog [ __ ] and I
started I don't know if I read first or
if I'd to start talking to you but there
was like this immediate like bromance
with his brain
John I've always said it is the smartest
guy he's funny really funny please the
smartest men I've ever met in my entire
life and I so so mean
thank you very much